how do you stay calm during what is now
apparently a national insurrection how
do you stay calm now there are two
answers the one is religious the other
is historical obviously the religious
answer is I save your lives you know
come on you can you know this
this flesh isn't gonna last forever this
matter isn't isn't the whole world we
should protect people's property we
should protect our civilization or our
cities but you know the same yet this
isn't the whole world and so in the
grand scheme of things the the
footlocker that just got robbed is is
not you know the be-all and end-all it's
very sad for the business owner it's
wrong but you know it's not not the end
of the world also if you have this
religious point of view you realize the
imagination of man's heart is evil from
the beginning we're in a fallen world
there is original sin we're not going to
get utopia on earth America wonderful
country as it is is not this utopia it's
not going to be perfect there's always
going to be injustice so that's the way
of the world that's the religious answer
the other one is historical lots of bad
things happen in history I mean if you
look back at not just the recent past
but the longer past though wait longer
past go back actually to the historical
accounts in the Bible things go real bad
real fast there are lots of atrocities
there's lots of precedent you know a lot
of people are comparing this race riot
to the 1992 riots and there are some
analogs and some not analogs meaning in
in 1992 these race riots began because
Rodney King was beaten by the police and
then the police officers who were
involved were acquitted of the crime
because they were acquitted
people view this as an injustice and
there were race riots there are some
analogy here except where is the
injustice currently being committed a
guy was killed
very likely through police brutality
then the cop involved was fired and then
he was charged with murder what what
next what else what else could be done
there's nothing else to be the guys
being charged with murder
there's no it's not like he was
acquitted right he gets to walk
scot-free
there's nothing else
to be done there's so there's no
resolution to this there's no there's no
answer it's just this venting of
frustration that I think comes from from
ignorance and isolation and a loss of of
what the civilization is built on that
happens in history nations rise nations
peak nations fall civilizations rise
they peak they fall lots of bad things
lots of suffering the world continues to
spin the world goes on there will be you
know if you have a progressive vision of
the world then things have to keep
getting better and better and better and
better in everything in the past was bad
and everything in the future is getting
better and better and the reason why
progressives and liberals are so
disillusioned is because that doesn't
actually happen way things the way
things really happen is it's a bad
things happen then maybe some good
things happen but then some more bad
things happen and now we're in the midst
of one of these bad things happening and
guess what some good things will happen
again that's the goodness and the bad
news just and bad things will happen
after that that's the way of the world
it's not particularly ideological it's
much more practical it's much more
realistic but I think all of the madness
that we're looking at right now has been
caused by ideological delusions and the
only way we're going to get back to any
sense of normalcy is by dispelling those
illusions and accepting occasionally a
bitter pill but ultimately a much more
comforting one reality
[Music]
you
[Music]